the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
reluctant to say good afternoon given
the weather but but I'll say it anyway I
guess now we all do know that we live in
in Boston and I should say I hope none
of you were affected too much by the
fire yesterday in Cambridge but that
seems to have been a pretty disastrous
event for some anyway here's the reading
this is a chapter in the book on
clustering a topic that Professor
Grimson introduced last week and I'm
going to try and finish up with respect
to this course today though not with
respect to everything there is to know
about clustering quickly just reviewing
where we were we're in the unit of the
course on machine learning and we always
follow the same paradigm we observe some
set of examples which we call the
training data we try and infer something
about the process that created those
examples and then we use inference
techniques different kinds of techniques
to make predictions about previously
unseen data we call that the test data
as Professor Grimson said you can think
of two broad classes supervised where we
have a set of examples in some label
associated with the example
democrat-republican smart dumb whatever
you want to associate with them and then
we try and infer the labels or
unsupervised where we're given a set of
feature vectors without labels and then
we attempt to group them into natural
clusters that's going to be today's
topic clustering
so clustering is an optimization problem
as we'll see later supervised machine
learning is also an optimization problem
clusterings are rather simple one we're
going to start first with the notion of
variability so this little C is a single
cluster and we're going to talk about
the variability in that cluster of the
sum of the distance between the mean of
the cluster and each example in the
cluster and then we square it okay
pretty straightforward for the moment we
can just assume that we're using look
Euclidean distance as our distance
metric Mankowski with P equals two so
variability should look pretty similar
to something we've seen before right
it's not quite variance right but it's
very close in a minute we'll look at why
it's different and then we can look at
the dissimilarity of a set of clusters a
group of clusters which I'm writing is
capital C and that's just the sum of all
the variabilities now if I had divided
variability by the size of the cluster
what would I have something we've seen
before would that be somebody isn't that
just the variance so the question is why
am I not doing that if up till now we
always wanted to talk about variance why
suddenly am I not doing it why do I
define this notion of variability
instead of good old variance any
thoughts
what am i accomplishing by not dividing
by the size of the cluster or what would
happen if I did divide by the size of
the cluster yes
absolutely I'd normalize it that's
exactly what it would be doing and what
might be good or bad about normalizing
it what does it sensually mean to
normalize it means that the penalty for
a big cluster with a lot of variants in
it is no higher than the penalty of a
tiny little cluster with a lot of
variance in it by not normalizing what
I'm saying is I want to penalize big
highly diverse clusters more than small
highly diverse clusters okay and if you
think about it that probably makes sense
you know big and bad is worse than small
and bad all right so now we define the
objective function and can we say that
the optimization problem we want to
solve by clustering is simply finding a
capital C that minimal minimizes
dissimilarity is that a reasonable
definition well hint no what foolish
thing could we do that would optimize
that objective function yeah yeah I
could have the same number of clusters
as points assign each point to its own
cluster whoops Oh almost a relay the
dissimilarity of each cluster would be 0
but the variability would be 0 so the
dissimilarity be zero and I just solved
the problem well that's clearly not a
very useful thing to do so
well what happen what do you think we do
to get around that yeah we apply a
constraint exactly
and so we have to pick some constraint
what would be a suitable constraint for
example well maybe we'd say okay the
clusters have to have some minimum
distance between them or and this is the
constraint we'll be using today we could
constrain the number of clusters so all
right I only want to have at most five
clusters do the best you can to minimize
dissimilarity but you're not allowed to
use more than five clusters that's the
most common constraint that gets placed
in the problem all right we're going to
look at two algorithms maybe I should
say two methods because they're multiple
implementations of these methods the
first is called hierarchical clustering
and the second is called k-means there
should be an S on the word mean there
sorry about that alright let's look at
hierarchical clustering first it's
strange algorithm we start by assigning
each item each example to its own
cluster so this is the trivial solution
we talked about before so if you have n
items you now have n clusters each
containing just one item it's the next
step we find the two most similar
clusters we have and merge them into a
single cluster so that now instead of n
clusters we have n minus 1 clusters and
we continue this process until all items
are clustered into a single cluster of
size n now of course that's kind of
silly because if all I wanted to put
them all in a single cluster I don't
need to iterate I just go wham right but
what's interesting about hierarchical
clustering is you stop it typically
somewhere along the way
you produce something called the
dendogram they write that down
at each step here that shows you what
you've merged thus far we'll see an
example of that shortly and then you can
have some stopping criteria we'll talk
about that this is called agglomerated
hierarchical clustering because we start
with a bunch of things and we
agglomerate them that is to say we put
them together
alright makes sense well there's a catch
what do we mean by distance and there
are multiple plausible definitions of
distance and you would get a different
answer depending upon which measure you
used these are called linkage metrics
the most common one used is probably
single linkage and that says the
distance between a pair of clusters is
equal to the shortest distance from any
member of one cluster to any member of
the other cluster so if I have two
clusters here and here and they have
bunches of points in them single linkage
distance would say well let's use these
two points which are the closest and the
distance between these two is the
distance between the clusters you can
also use complete linkage
and that says the distance between any
two clusters is equal to the greatest
distance from any member to any other
member okay so if we had the same
picture we had before probably not the
same picture but it's a picture whoops
then we would say well I guess complete
linkage is probably the distance maybe
between those two and finally not
surprisingly you can take the average
distance these are all plausible metrics
they're all used and practiced for
different kinds of results depending
upon the application of the clustering
alright let's look an example so what I
have here is the air distance between
six different cities Boston New York
Chicago Denver San Francisco and Seattle
and now let's say we want to cluster
these airports just based upon their
distance so we start the first piece of
our dendogram says well alright I have
six cities I have six clusters each
containing one city all right what
happens next what's the next level going
to look like yeah I'm going to join
Boston and New York as improbable as
that sounds all right so that's the next
level and if for some reason I only
wanted to have five clusters well I
could stop here next what happens well I
look at it I say well I'll join up
Chicago
with Boston and New York all right what
do I get at the next level somebody yeah
doesn't look like it to me if you look
at San Francisco in Seattle they are
eight hundred and eight miles and Denver
and San Francisco is twelve thirty five
so I end up in fact joining San
Francisco in Seattle ah well that
explains why I need my hearing fixed all
right so I combined San Francisco and
Seattle and now it gets interesting I
have two choices with Denver obviously
they're only two choices and which I
choose depends upon which linkage
criterion I use from using single
linkage well then Denver gets joined
with Boston New York and Chicago because
it's closer to Chicago than it is to
either San Francisco or Seattle but if I
use complete linkage it gets joined up
with San Francisco in Seattle because it
is further from Boston than it is from I
guess it's San Francisco or Seattle
whichever it is right so this is a place
where you see what I answer I get
depends upon the linkage criteria and
then if I want I can consider to the
next step and just join them all all
right
that's hierarchical clustering so it's
good because you get this whole history
of the dendogram and you get to look at
it so well all right that looks pretty
good
I'll stick with this clustering it's
deterministic
given a linkage criteria and you always
get the same answer there's nothing
random here notice by the way the answer
might not be optimal with regards to
that linkage criteria why not what kind
of algorithm is this
it's a greedy algorithm exactly and so
I'm making locally optimal decisions at
each point which may or may not be
globally optimal it's flexible choosing
different linkage criteria I get
different results but it's also
potentially really really slow this is
not something you want to do on a
million examples the naive algorithm the
one I just sort of showed you is n cubed
and cubed is typically impractical for
some linkage criteria for example single
linkage there exists very clever N
squared algorithms for others you can't
beat n cubed
but even N squared is really not very
good which gets me to a much faster
greedy algorithm called k-means now the
K in k-means is the number of clusters
you want so the catch with k-means is if
you don't have any idea how many
clusters you want it's it's
problematical whereas hierarchical you
get to inspect it and see what you're
getting if you know how many you want
it's a good choice because it's much
faster all right
the algorithm again is very simple this
is the one that Professor Grimson
briefly discussed you randomly choose K
examples as your initial centroids
doesn't matter which of the examples you
choose then you create K clusters
by assigning each example to the closest
centroid compute K new centroids by
averaging the examples in each cluster
so in the first iteration the centroids
are all examples that you started with
but after that they're probably not
examples because you're now taking the
average of two examples which may not
correspond to any example you have
actually the average of n examples and
then you just keep doing this until the
centroids don't move right once you go
through one iteration where they don't
move there's no point in recomputing
them again and again and again so it is
converged so let's look at the
complexity well at the moment we can't
tell you how many iterations you're
going to have but what's the complexity
of one iteration well let's think about
what you're doing here
you've got K centroids now I have to
take each example and compare it to each
in a naively at least to each centroid
to see which it's closest to right so
that's K comparisons per example so
that's K times n times D where how much
time each of these comparison takes
which is likely to depend upon the
dimensionality of the features right
just the Euclidean distance for example
but this is a way small number than N
squared typically so each iteration is
pretty quick and in practice as we'll
see this typically converges quite
quickly so you usually need a very small
number of
iterations so it is quite efficient and
then there are various ways you can
optimize it to make it even more
efficient this is the most commonly used
clustering algorithm because it works
really fast let's look at an example so
I've got a bunch of blue points here and
I actually wrote the code to do this I'm
not going to show you the code and I
chose for centroids at random colored
stars a green one a fuchsia colored one
a red one and a blue one
so maybe they're not the ones you would
have chosen but there they are
and I then having chosen them assign
each point to one of those centroids
whichever one is closest to alright step
one
and then I recompute the centroids let's
go back so we're here and these are the
initial centroids now when I find the
new centroids if we look at where the
red one is the red one is this point
this point in this point clearly the new
centroid is going to move right it's
going to move somewhere along in here or
something like that right so we'll get
those new centroids there it is and now
will reassign points and what we'll see
is this point is now closer to the red
star than it is to the fuchsia star
having because we've moved the red star
whoops that one sorry said the wrong
thing they were ready to start with this
one is now suddenly closer to the purple
so it into the red it will get recolored
we compute the new centroids we're going
to move something again we continue
points will move around this time we
move two points here we go again notice
again the centroids don't correspond to
actual examples this one is close but
it's not really one of them move to more
recompute centroids and we're done so
here we've converged and I think it was
five iterations and nothing will move
again all right that makes sense to
everybody so it's pretty simple what are
the downsides well choosing K foolishly
can lead to strange results so if I
chose k equal to three looking at this
particular arrangement of points it's
not obvious what quote the right answer
is right maybe it's making all of this
one cluster I don't know
but they're a weird caves and if you
choose a K that is nonsensical with
respect to your data then your
clustering will be nonsensical so that's
one problem we have to think about how
do we choose K another problem this is
one somebody raised last time is that
the results can depend upon the initial
centroids unlike hierarchical clustering
k-means is non-deterministic depending
upon what random examples we choose we
can get a different number of iterations
if we choose them poorly it could take
longer to converge more worrisome you
get a different answer you're running
this greedy algorithm and you might
actually get to a different place
depending upon which centroids you chose
so these are the two issues we have to
think about dealing with so let's first
think about choosing K what often
happens is people choose K using a
priori knowledge about the application
you know if I'm in medicine
I actually know that there are only five
different kinds of bacteria in the world
that's true I mean there's sub species
but five large categories and if I had a
bunch of bacterium I wanted to cluster
Majestic k equal to five maybe I believe
there are only two kinds of people into
the world those who are at MIT and those
who are not and so I'll choose K equal
to two often we know enough about the
application we can choose K as we'll see
later often we can think we do when we
don't a better approach is to search for
a good k
so you can try different values of K and
evaluate the quality of the result
assuming you have some metric as to see
I like this clustering I don't like this
clustering and we'll talk about how to
do that in detail or you can run
hierarchical clustering on a subset of
data I've got a million points all right
what I'm going to do is take a subset of
a thousand of them or ten thousand run
hierarchical clustering from that get a
sense of the structure underlying the
data beside K should be six and then run
k-means with k equal six people often do
this they run a hierarchical clustering
on a small subset of the data and then
choose k and we'll look but what the one
we're going to look at is that one
what about unlucky centroids so here I
got same points we started with
different initial centroids I've got a
fuchsia one the black one and then I've
got red and blue down here which I
happen to accidentally choose close to
one another well if I start with these
centroids certainly you would expect
things to take longer to converge but in
fact what happens is this I get to this
assignment of blue this assignment of
red and I'm done it converges on this
which probably is not what we wanted out
of this maybe it is but the fact that I
converged on some very different place
shows that it's a real weakness of the
algorithm that it's sensitive to the
randomly chosen initial conditions well
a couple of things you can do about that
you could be clever and try and select
good initial centroids so people often
will do that and what they'll do is try
and just make sure that they're
distributed over the space so they would
look at some picture like this and say
well let's just put my centroids at the
corners or something like that so that
they're far apart another approach is to
try multiple sets of randomly chosen
centroids and then just select the best
results and that's what this little
algorithm on the screen does so I'll say
best is equal to K means of the points
themselves or something then 40 and
range number of trials I'll say C equals
K means of points and I'll just keep
track and choose the one with the least
dissimilarity the thing I'm trying to
minimize okay
the first one is got all the points in
one cluster so it's very dissimilar and
then I'll just keep generating four
different K's and I'll choose the K that
seems to be the best that does the best
job of minimizing my objective function
and this is a very common solution by
the way for any randomized greedy
algorithm and there are a lot of
randomized greedy algorithms that you
just choose of multiple initial
conditions try them all out and pick the
best all right now I want to show you a
slightly more real example so this is a
file we've got with medical patients and
we're going to try and cluster them and
see whether the clusters tell us
anything about the probability
of them dying of a heart attack in say
the next year or some period of time so
to simplify things and this is something
I have done with research but we're
looking at only four features here the
heart rate in beats per minute the
number of previous heart attacks the age
and something called ST elevation a
binary attribute so the first three are
obvious if you take an ECG of somebody's
heart it looks like this this is a
normal one they have the s the T and
then there's this region between the S
wave and the T wave and if it's higher
hence elevated that's a bad thing and so
this is about the first thing that they
measure if someone is having cardiac
problems do they have ST elevation and
then with each patient we're going to
have an outcome whether they died and
it's related to the features but it's
probabilistic not deterministic so for
example an older person of multiple
heart attacks is at higher risk than a
young person who's never had a heart
attack that doesn't mean though that the
older person will die first it's just
more probable we're going to take this
data we're going to cluster it and then
we're going to look at what's called the
purity of the clusters relative to the
outcomes so is the cluster say enriched
by people who died now if you have one
cluster and everyone in it died then the
clustering is clearly finding some
structure related to the outcome
so the file is in the zip file I
uploaded it looks more or less like this
right so it's very straightforward the
outcomes are binary one is a positive
outcome strangely enough in the medical
jargon a pot is a positive outcome I
guess maybe if you're responsible for
the medical bills it's positive if
you're the patient it's hard to think of
it as a good thing
nevertheless that's the way that they
talk and the others are all there right
heart rate other things all right let's
look at some code so I've extracted some
code I'm not going to show you all of it
there's quite a lot of it as you'll see
so we'll start there's one of the files
you got is called cluster dot pie I
decided there was enough code I didn't
want to put it all in one file I was
getting confused so I said let me create
a file that has some of the code and a
different file that will then import it
and use it
cluster has things that are pretty much
unrelated to this example but just
useful for clustering so an example here
has name features and label and really
the only interesting thing in it and
it's not that interesting is distance
and the fact that I'm using Mankowski
with two says we're using Euclidean
distance class cluster it's a lot more
code to that one so we start with a
non-empty list of examples that's what
an it does you can imagine what the code
looks like or you can look at it update
is interesting in that it takes the
cluster and examples and puts them in if
you think of k-means in the in the
closest to the previous centroids and
then returns the amount the centroid has
changed so if the centroid has changed
by zero and it you don't have anything
right creates the new set new cluster
and the most interesting thing is
compute centroid and if you look at this
code you can see that I'm a slightly
unreconstructed Python to programmers I
just noticed this I really shouldn't
have written zero point zero I should
have just written zero but in Python two
you had to write that point zero sorry
about that
thought I'd fix these anyway so how do
we compute the centroid we start by
creating an array of all zeros the
dimensionality is the number of features
in the example it's it's one of the
methods from I didn't put up on the
PowerPoint and then for ian's examples
I'm going to add two vowels I get
features and then I'm just going to
divide Valve's by the length of
self-taught examples a number of
examples so now you see why I made it a
pylab array or a numpy array rather than
a list so I could do nice things like
divide the whole thing in one expression
as you do math many kind of math things
you'll find these arrays are incredibly
convenient rather than having to write
recursive functions or do bunches of
iterations the fact that you can do it
in one keystroke is incredibly nice and
then I'm going to return the centroid
variability is exactly what we saw in
the formula and then just for fun so you
could see this I used an iterator here I
don't know that any of you have used the
yield statement in Python I recommend it
it
very convenient one of the nice things
about Python is almost anything that's
built in you can make your own version
of it and so once I've done this if C is
a cluster I can now write something like
for C in Big C and this will make it
work just like iterating over a list
right so this makes it possible to
iterate over it if you haven't read
about yield you probably should read the
probably about two paragraphs in the
textbook explaining how it works
but it's very convenient dissimilarity
we've already seen all right now we get
to patience this is in the file
lect twelve lecture twelve dot pi in
addition to importing the usual suspects
of Pi lab and numpy and probably it
should import random to it imports
cluster the one we just looked at and so
patient is a sub type of cluster dot
example then I'm going to define this
interesting thing called scale
attributes so you might remember in the
last lecture when Professor Grimson was
looking at these reptiles he ran into
this problem about alligators looking
like chickens because they each had a
large number of legs and he said well
what can we do to get around this well
we can represent the feature as a binary
number has legs doesn't have legs 0 or 1
and the problem he was dealing with is
that when you have a feature vector and
the dynamic range of some features is
much greater than the others they tend
to dominate because the distances just
look
bigger when you get Euclidean distance
so for example if we wanted to cluster
the people in this room and I had one
feature that was say one from ale and
zero for female and another feature that
was one for wears glasses zeros for
doesn't wear glasses and then a third
feature which was weight and I clustered
them well weight would always completely
dominate the Euclidean distance right
because the dynamic range of the weights
in this room is much higher than the
dynamic range of 0 to 1 and so for the
reptiles he said well okay we'll just
make it a binary variable but maybe we
don't want to make weight a binary
variable because maybe it is something
we want to take into account so what we
do is we scale it so this is a method
called Z scaling more general than just
making things 0 or 1 it's a simple code
it takes in all of the values of a
specific feature and then perform some
simple calculations and when it's done
the resulting array it returns has a
known mean and a known standard
deviation so what's the mean going to be
it's always going to be the same thing
independent of the initial values take a
look at the code try and see if you can
figure it out anybody want to take a
guess at it 0 right so the mean will
always be 0 and the standard deviation a
little harder to figure but it will
always be 1
okay so it's done this scaling this is a
very common kind of scaling called Z
scaling the other way people scale is
interpolate they take the smallest value
and call it zero the biggest value they
call it one and then they do a linear
interpolation of all the values between
zero and one so the range is zero to one
that's also very common so this is a
general way to get all of the features
sort of in the same ballpark so that we
can compare them and we'll look at what
happens when we scale and when we don't
scale and that's why my get data
function has this parameter to scale it
either creates a set of examples with
the attributes as initially or scaled
and then there's k-means it's exactly
the algorithm I showed you with one
little wrinkle which is this part you
don't want to end up with empty clusters
if I tell you I want four clusters I
don't mean I want three with examples
and one that's empty right because then
I really don't have four clusters and so
this is one of multiple ways to avoid
having empty clusters basically what I
did here is said well I'm going to try a
lot of different initial conditions if
one of them is so unlucky to give me an
empty cluster I'm just going to skip it
and go on to the next one by raising a
value error empty cluster and if you
look at the code you'll see how this
value error is used and then try k-means
will call k-means numb trial times each
one getting a different set of initial
centroids and return the result with the
lowest dissimilarity then I have various
ways to examine the results nothing very
interesting and here's the key place
where we're
to run the whole thing we'll get the
data initially not scaling it because
remember it defaults to true then
initially I'm only going to try 1k
cables - and we'll call test clustering
with the patients the number of cluster
is K I put in seed as a parameter here
because I wanted to be able to play with
it and make sure I got different things
for 0 1 1 & 2
just as a testing thing and 5 trials
it's defaulting to and then we'll look
at test clustering is returning the
fraction of positive examples for each
cluster okay so let's see what happens
when we run it
all right so we got two clusters cluster
of size 118 with 0.3 305 and a cluster
of size 132 with a positive fraction of
point quadruple 3 should we be happy
does our clustering tell us anything
somehow correspond to the expected
outcome for patients here probably not
right those numbers are pretty much
indistinguishable statistically and
you'd have to guess that the fraction of
positives in the whole population is
around 0.33 right that about a third of
these people died of their heart attack
and I might as well have assigned them
randomly to the two clusters right
there's not much difference between this
in which you would get with the random
result well why do we think that's true
because I didn't scale right and so one
of the issues we had to deal with is
well age had a big dynamic range and say
st-elevation which I told you is highly
diagnostic was either 0 or 1 and so
probably everything is getting swamped
by age or something else right all right
so we have an easy way to fix that
we'll just scale the data now let's see
what we get
all right that's interesting with
casting rule good grief that caught me
by surprise
hmm good thing I have the answers in
PowerPoint to show you because the code
doesn't seem to be working
try it once more
No all right well in the interest of
getting it through this lecture on
schedule
we'll go look at the results that we get
I got last time I ran it all right when
I scaled what we see here is that now
there's a pretty dramatic difference
right one of the clusters is a much
higher fraction of positive patients
than others but it's still a bit
problematic so this has pretty good
specificity of positive predictive value
but it's sensitivity is lousy remember a
third of our initial population more or
less was positive 26 is way less than a
third so in fact I've got a class a
cluster that is strongly enriched but
I'm still lumping most of the positive
patients into the other cluster and in
fact there are 83 positives or some code
to do that and so we see that of the 83
positives only this classes which is 70%
positive only has 26 in it to start with
it so I'm clearly missing most of the
positives so why well my hypothesis was
the different subgroups of positive
patients have different characteristics
and so we could test this by trying
other values of K to see with we would
get more clusters so here I said let's
try K equals to four and six and here's
what I got
I ran that so what you'll notice here as
we get to say for that I have two
clusters this one and this one which are
heavily enriched with positive patients
26 as before in the first one but 76
patients in the third one so I'm now
getting a much higher fraction of
patients in one of the quote risky
clusters and I can continue to do that
but it if I look at K equals 6 we now
look at the positive clusters there were
three of them significantly positive but
I'm not really getting a lot more
patients total so maybe four is the
right answer so what you see here is
that we have at least two parameters to
play with scaling and K even though I
was only wanted a structure that would
separate the risk high risk patients
from the lower risk which is why started
with two I later discovered that in fact
there are multiple reasons for being a
high risk and so maybe one of these
clusters is heavily enriched by old
people maybe another one is heavily
enriched by people who have had three
heart attacks in the past or
st-elevation or some combination and
when I had only two clusters I couldn't
get that fine gradation so this is what
data scientists spend their time doing
when they're doing clustering is they
actually have multiple parameters they
try different things out they look at
the results and that's why you actually
have to think to manipulate data rather
than just push a button and wait for the
answer all right more of this general
topic
on Wednesday when we're going to talk
about classification thank you